[Musik]
ich bereue bereue bereue dass ich so
viel scheiß gemacht und bereue dass ich
chancen nicht genutzt haben und einfach
normale gang haben uns einfach im islam
so kann man normal aber ja ich bereue
fehler
michael kommt als kind in ein heim ihre
jugend verbringt sie oft die
psychiatrischen kliniken dass ich mich
auch eine umbringe richtig verändert ihr
äußeres aber unverändert bleibt der
selbsthass selten erlebt die
unbeschwerte momente
wie kann jemand tritt fassen dessen
leben schon früh aus den fugen geriet
wie reagiert das gesundheits und
sozialwesen auf einem menschen mit
psychischen problemen diese fragen
beschäftige mich während der
dreharbeiten mit michael die 14 jahre
dauerten
[Musik]
das schloss kosten im kanton aargau ist
ein kinderheim
bei ihrem einzug ins heim wird michel
von ihrer familie begleitet die
elfjährige sehe ich hier zum ersten mal
pro woche da gemacht du kannst so wie
ihr wollt ihr dass couch lag
der alltag im heim ist rau michelles
mutter die alleinerziehende kam mit
ihrer tochter nicht mehr zurecht es ist
immer eine unruhige see sicher schwerer
gewalt- und jetzt schaut einfach wieder
da jetzt einfach ruhe
die elfjährige hat mühe mit autoritäten
[Musik]
jahre später treffe ich mich schnell
wieder
sie ist 17 und macht ein hauswirtschafts
praktikum in einer wohngemeinschaft und
winchester es ist gut
ich finde ich bin zu jung für da also
die jungs mit abstand aber ich wollte
sowieso mit alten liebschaft wenn ihr
jetzt in einem praktikum da und ich
find's gut
seit unserer letzten begegnung vor sechs
jahren hat sie nie ein richtiges zuhause
gefunden
hinter ihr liegt eine odyssee durch rund
20 heime und soziale institutionen die
wohngemeinschaft bietet menschen mit
unterschiedlichsten problemen einen
lebensraum zu bewohnerinnen tore hat sie
ein besonders enges verhältnis
einerseits macht ein praktikum auf der
anderen seite ist sie selber patientin
[Musik]
michelle ist noch immer psychisch
instabil
vor zwei wochen wollte sie sich das
leben nehmen
[Musik]
ich habe mir das problem abgewiesen oder
zug wissen oder nicht akzeptiert werden
dass ich ins studio gehe und das musst
du dich immer das gleiche und sah dass
ich dann im wortlaut und den
suizidversuch machen und das ist steht
den aussie
ich bin also ab gewisse wurde verboten
und das hat mich sehr verletzt und dann
ich denke ja wenn mich die person auch
nicht worden war
ich hasse mich passen charakterlich hat
mir einmal mega glücklich und eine
plötzliche panik optimiert
ich weiß nicht was das runde kann jetzt
von mir also was in der vergangenheit
ist und die kindheit hat sie
traumatisiert darüber reden möchte sie
nicht ihre geschiedene mutter will kein
weiterer sind wir geben
michael war sechs als ihren vater zum
letzten mal sah
auch ihre erlebnisse in den heimen
stehen ihr verhalten wie mehrere zeugen
entwickelt mitte zieht und es muss immer
das infektions metal bh und und ich
wasche meine hand der bürger weiß nicht
wie viel am tag
und wenn mich dann aber an letzter
stelle dann muss ich die stelle gottes
infizieren weil man angst fragte
bakterien und so
die klinik königsfelden im aargauischen
windisch michel wurde nach einem
zwischenfall in der wohngemeinschaft in
die psychiatrie eingewiesen
daraufhin wollte sich die 17 jährige
erneut das leben nehmen und dann bin ich
voll ausgelastet und sondern hat sich
auch ein anderer bewohner trick messe
und so kann ich dir vorweg schöpfer
doch dann haben sie mich wieder
produziert da bin ich voll ausgelastet
messer auf sie los
aber es ist nichts passiert bis passiert
mit ihr im nachhinein bisher bewusst
hast du da gemacht hat oder weißt du gar
nimmer was damit die vorsicht ja doch
wenn man sie denn schon bewusst und es
tut mir leid ursache ihre in stabilen
persönlichkeit könnte eine borderline
störung sein vermuten die ärzte durch
eine genaue diagnose wird in der schweiz
erst im erwachsenenalter gestellt
anstrengender so stressig es wird noch
schneller befördert
sie nimmt starke medikamente und wird
therapeutisch behandelt
ihr unberechenbares verhalten bringt das
sozial- und gesundheitssystem an seine
grenzen
zurück in die wohngemeinschaft darf sie
nicht mehr wieso ist jetzt wieder gut
mit ihm ich danke wenn es möglich ist
das aber schwierig für dich zum wie so
ein platz finden
ja schon aber weil ich 67 fest das ist
probleme und die einnahmen rechnen mit
ihr wurde
67 warum dann ja weil ich ein
beratungstag locker bin also würden wir
sie ja so schön ist es da drinnen das am
besten kontrollieren ja schon aus spitze
aber ich wäre ja wie schiesser
aufenthalt hinter geschlossenen
jugendabteilung dauert ein halbes jahr
kaspar so lautet der name ihres hundes
michele legte sich das tier zu nachdem
sie die klinik verlassen hatte mit dem
vierbeiner übernimmt die inzwischen
18-jährige verantwortung
sie wolle aber nicht nur gut für den
hund sorgen sondern auch für sich selber
wie gott sehr michael gut sehr gut sich
ja das ist der grund er war damals ja
ich bin's klinikum sachen machen was ihr
wollt amini freiheit freiheit designtes
andere ich natürlich weiß wo man dann
auch mal gedanken gemacht ich hab mich
einfach nur schaffen bis reich nie
gewonnen und nach anna-lena
fachangestellte gesundheit
der plan wie das möchte ich natürlich
ganz so und sie ja aber ich denke im
moment bin ich schon eher stabil ist und
kann ich hoffe es wird einfach immer
besser
so wird habe ich mich an ihr gefühlt pc
zurzeit sozialhilfe und wohnbau einer
kollegin das wiedersehen stimmt mich
zuversichtlich vielleicht geht es nun
wirklich aufwärts mit dir
[Musik]
die ernüchterung folgt ein halbes jahr
später ich treffe auf eine völlig
veränderte mich schöner erneut durchlebt
sie eine schwere zeit
die 19 jährige wohnt bei petra die
beiden lernten sich in der psychiatrie
kennen
du bist jetzt dreht sie die klinik
kritik sie was ich gewohnt sexy und weil
ich biete dazu mal also grad minus 701
raum ist herz zerrissen ist
michael gab ihren hund weg weil sie zu
wenig geld hatte und für ihn zu sorgen
beide frauen sind auf einem
medikamentencocktail angewiesen um
einigermaßen stabil zu bleiben
sowohl petra als auch michelle haben ein
ähnliches schicksal und leiden unter
demselben 2
[Musik]
dort wo gegen mich gerichtet ist du
nicht mehr sauberes land in dem das ich
mal schnyder in dem moment spüre ich
mich nicht und werde mich aber gespürt
und dennis schmidt also für mich - van
thiel
also ich glaube die wird die luft wo im
rennen ist noch fraglich
durchschnittsnutzer und ich habe da habe
ich wieder zu mir wenn über krieg und
blogs laufen dann weiß ich auch dass wir
in new york für sie einfach angst vor
allem deshalb misslangen heimsieben
hauptsache ich spiele jeden tag zum
anderen eine minimale gefüllt sind
miriam hartmann ist mittels beiständin
sie hat für ihre klientin einen platz in
einer sozialen einrichtung gefunden
das zusammenleben mit kollegin petra war
schwierig durch michael vielleicht die
wohnung
[Musik]
ja
billen fordert so fragt sie
man kann machen was ich habe und jetzt
muss ich wollte das einfach mehr hat mit
strukturen mit regeln und so dass sie
mit dem druck nicht umgehen sodass man
sie am schluss den einfach mit
psychiatrie platziert wie das neue
station auf ihrem weg zu mehr stabilität
das gärtnerhaus im aargauischen
meisterschwanden bietet menschen die
psychischen problemen geschützte
arbeitsplätze an
ist jetzt alles neu
new york may lead ich hoffe er ist ja
wahr
im gärtnerhaus lernt michel zu arbeiten
zwei stunden pro tag hält sie es bereits
aus sind ganz mensch eigentlich als
verstand nicht verschoben werden muss
alle in dem haus blieben die hoffnung
hält nicht lange an
nach einem halben jahr verlässt michael
von sich aus das gärtnerhaus der alltag
mit enger tagesstruktur überfordert sie
inzwischen 21 jährige wohnt seit einem
halben jahr weihnachten auch erich in
heimen aufgewachsen und dort kennen sich
die beiden staaten und von meiner jk und
gar nicht was heute denn was bringt so
mein antreten oder machen wir persönlich
und ja dann hat das hat gerade das
zimmer flex ihr schon darum kredit sogar
ganz gut mitgenommen so herr deppe die
sie konflikten aber das christliche dorf
stellt man fest dass die füße platt
miteinander hier ja in der hand ob die
meinungsverschiedenheiten
der 20-jährige nato arbeite temporär bei
der post michel hat weder eine
ausbildung nach arbeit
sie bezieht mittlerweile eine iv-rente
auf der suche nach ein bisschen glück
flüchten sie sich gelegentlich in den
rausch das ist so das spektrum ja auch
sein dass ich absolut das gütesiegel der
gesundheits leben naja aber sagst du zu
hause mitnehmen jetzt nicht so dass mir
das jetzt auch woche und wird wie vier
marineschiffe und das passierte schon in
sich bei onlinesucht die als ich auf
meinte tag auf dann 3 widerrufen oder
schwimme ich das problem
ich nehme jetzt vielleicht zwei tage
hinter dem koks oder so nach und eine
kurze dafür aber ich das besonders
gefährlich ein problem hat na ja genau
das getan was macht glücklich und so mit
dem philipp noch das nicht gern das ist
so eine sache für sich
das stimmt aber trotzdem der moment sei
für das lohnt sich das
[Musik]
drogen ermöglichen ihren flüchtiges hoch
der fall danach ist umso tiefer michels
gedanken sind schwermütig märz wenig
halt immer noch runter bin ich merke wie
erschöpft ich doch eigentlich voll aber
bin will ich doch eigentlich schon
durchgemacht haben wir vielleicht schon
kämpft haben und dass das eigentlich
fern
ja weil ich danke ich bin nicht
wiederkommen aber wie sie jetzt gesagt
also ich finde ich bin nicht wiederholen
was wäre ein weiterer job als mit einer
weinlaube und psychisch hat halt auch
stabil weil ich mach ich doch immer
wieder alles kaputt wird - stimmig schon
kriegt sie möchte freiwillig zurück in
die psychiatrie um wieder tritt zu
fassen das ist nicht einfach dem ihr
zustand wird nicht als akut eingestuft
tage später sendet sie mir ein
handy-video habe die klinik froh dass
ich in amerika etat um das ist weil ich
vorher schon monate war noch mit doch an
die termine die psychiaterin
ja man kann vielleicht hätte das theater
überlegen ich hab das nicht so gut ich
klinke für zur rede
ja aber so ist es mal ein paar wochen
später hat es geklappt michaelis und
patienten in der psychiatrischen klinik
im bernischen langenthal aufgrund ihrer
stimmungsschwankungen diagnostiziert man
bei ihr eine borderline störung
angefangen mit therapie ist neu für mich
aber einstimmig schwung bis zum
gehtnichtmehr den rebellen über ca
dann wird noch besprochen besuch muss da
schon habe damit sind in dem katrin
walter burri hat für mich eine
überraschende antwort was brauchst dazu
geduld und glaube
ich bin jetzt forscher vom fell das
gelernte sport sehen und ja aber wenn es
froh diese kommen usa machte julian
jungs trend mit ganz gut so widmann
ich habe meine aussage in dem moment
weil man nicht weiß wo sie zwei stunden
die eine stunde drei monate lang war sie
in der psychiatrie heute vielleicht
sieht die klinik
man hat eigentlich folglich ich nehme
keine drogen mehr und ich konsumiere
auto und ich wollte aber dennoch sei es
besser so deute klinik kann sie durchaus
bank verkauft und gesetze der mathematik
berühmt aus ja sehr schwierige
situationen gebe aufenthalt und jannik
nach der halbzeit abstürzte aber das ist
eine auch sozusagen akzeptiert wenn wenn
du morgen holt jetzt einen eckball
heraus
es ist schon gut aber das ist
nicht so was macht ein bewertet die
größte gefühl verlässt jetzt auch klinik
ja so also mächtig viel mehr über wird
sicher bald ruhe weil ich belange zieht
auch sie und die lizenz herz gewachsen
und es wird sicher schwierig sieht
abschied aber ich komme mit dem
kühlwasser
das vielleicht jetzt neuanfang geht und
das beste draus machen
sie wird erwartet durch sind weder ihre
geschiedenen eltern noch der freund
als renner leistet max holliger
freiwillige sozialarbeit
er hat michael schon mehrmals chauffiert
weder vater noch mutter wolle michel bei
sich aufnehmen
die beziehung zu den eltern ist
angespannt und von nathan hat sie sich
getrennt
ja ist sowieso
wir sind sie der mann ist wage traurig
verordnet
wer das egal
ich muss aber bevor ich
irgendwelche bezügen ikone in der
stimmigen machen alles kaputt
jetzt nach einer zwischenlösung ist
geiler so dass blieben übrigens darum
auf wohnungssuche war sie bereits durch
niemand wollte er eine vermieten
trotz schwieriger honig wird jedoch
darüber verlieren was eigentlich
unlogisch regelmäßig und jo jo ok ok oh
mein gott
wieso
was ich dass mein gott oh mein gott zwar
ein alter radios 1960 nächsten sätzen
durch zimmermann das ist schreckt sie
etwas kostet jetzt so einen tag wie
astra statt 800 franken im monat also
schon da
ich weiß es nicht
mechanische gottheit plan ins hotel zu
ziehen war michaels entscheidung mangels
alternativen länger als drei monate in
der klinik langenthal zu bleiben ist
nicht möglich
manche mädchen land jetzt muss ich und
instabil ist in das hotel moskau
irgendwo in der pampa so kann man doch
dass fast mitverantworten aus
therapeutischer sicht ergibt sich das
praktikabel ist das hotel das ist
ziemlich saubere stadt ja das ist so ja
es gibt situationen wo man das gewünscht
habe womit finder ob sie sich jetzt will
ich mit so wie es im lehrbuch steht
instabilität ein stoischer muster oder
kurz vorher mit akteure sind die
betroffenen die wahl findet am 8
inzwischen wohnt michel zwei tage im
hotel es ist ein freitag gegen abend
erhalte ich von hier ein handy-video
bedeuten
ja immer einsamer noch überfordert was
mache ich hoffe ich halte das so nicht
passiert so gut trotzdem ist alles hätte
start ist einfach nicht
danach ruft michael in die kliniken
sie können nicht zurückkommen sagt man
hier die beiständin erreicht ja auch
nicht weniger verzweifelt wendet sie
sich hat mich nun kontaktiere ich die
klinik sage dass ich ein trauma anbahne
jetzt darf michael doch zurück jetzt
sagt dass die krankenkasse keine
verlängerung des aufenthaltes bezahlen
wollte
das ist ja erstaunlich dass ihr das
sagen die krankenhäuser sei die rege
konkreten antrag gestellt für lengerich
vom muff enthalten wie gesichert
überzeugt dass schon heute soll es
natürlich nicht also politisch sieht
also mit der tastatur muss schon sagen
es gibt dort nachher als punkt vor dem
ja das mindeste frage was würde ein
monat länger wirtschaft überhaupt nicht
so dass ein monat merklich und darum
herum die praxis dass man sagt das
probiere mich immer gut wenn man sie
nichts bringen und es später zu meiner
späteren zeitpunkt nochmals eine
therapie phase da jetzt kommt sehe ich
ein prozent förderung auf der längeren
prozess
das ist jetzt das betreute wohnen
morgen ab dass körper trainiert war dann
halt wieder ein paar wochen später
sendet mir michel diese aufnahme dank
des aufenthaltes in der klinik geht es
ihr wieder viel besser
sie hat sogar einen neuen freund
eineinhalb jahre später richtig klinik
in langenthal erneut ein zufluchtsort
für michael wir kennen uns nun schon elf
jahre lang und sind inzwischen per du
die 22 jährige erzählt mir was geschehen
war eskaliert immer wieder gewusst haben
was heißt diskutiert mit dem ex ja panik
rocker und staus auch immer wieder mal
ausgestellt und nicht im griff und jeder
kann einfach mal sagen sogar der fertig
und aber der weg ist so schlimm
eskaliert wo man das noch da wirklich
zurückgesetzt
die kurze beziehung mit diesem mann hat
jedoch langfristige folgen
sie ist im siebten monat schwanger
vaterschaft anerkennt fällst du bist
dann hast dass du sehr positiv
überrascht also eher auf kuranyi der
weiter
eigentlich kann ich schwanger werde
momentan nach dem pc sind roma das heißt
eine pc hormonstörung ist bei frauen
eine der häufigsten ursachen für
unfruchtbarkeit trotzdem wechseln ihr
ein neues leben heran
trixi das jetzt passiert ist ist
passiert ich bräuchte jetzt durch das
klar das war für lange zeit unser
letztes treffen michel will sich erstmal
nicht mehr filmen lassen
erst zweieinhalb jahre später kommt es
zu einem wiedersehen
ich treffe die inzwischen 25 jährige in
einem mutter-kind-haus im aargauischen
kindle dingen hat sich das muster red
mit mehreren familien das blonde mädchen
ist amelia die tochter von michael sie
wünscht dass sich die zweijährige nur
von hinten filme und das ist andrea
müller sozialpädagogin und leiterin des
mutter kind hauses
wir wohnten michel und amelia ein jahr
lang nach der geburt zog michelle mittag
waren hier ein eine zeit in der sie zu
sich kommen konnte für die
sozialpädagogin war indes eine
herausforderung mit kurzgeschichten
nämlich mit kontrollieren
dort wo du als ich sehr ruhiger mann
spielt er ja du du du kannst andere
wachstum jetzt kommt mit den emotionen
umgehen
was ist
meine freundin und ich vermute so bildet
das ist alles wurscht mutter freundin
also schon zusammen vermerkt und das ist
ein problem wenn ich nicht sogar die
wichtigste verbindung vom langweilig
andrea als sehr starker für mich
empfindet die lange aufenthalt in
institutionen hoffen ihr nur
vorübergehend nun scheint sich stabiler
geworden zu sein
inzwischen wohnt michelle auf dem land
in einem mehrfamilienhaus die junge
mutter nimmt seit längerem keine
medikamente mehr wegen ihrer borderline
störung
diese habe sie nämlich in den griff
bekommen
das grenzt nach
sie hat mich einfach grundsätzlich
verändert er sich schon aus der
verantwortung abstürzt und 100 gott
einfach nicht
danke dass sie mich noch eines dazu
gebracht hat so zivile hilfe und betrug
die einfach mal klar ich ziehe mir
nochmal zu führen hat aber trotzdem habe
ich eigentlich eine stabile
freundeskreis ich an schöner wohnen gut
da mal schauen was möglich und auch
michelles verhältnis zu den eltern hat
sich normalisiert
ihr leben gleicht einer achterbahn seit
zwei jahren ist sie nun psychisch stabil
so lange bin ich zuvor oder media gmbh
nehmen und das werde ich nicht
feststellen weil das ist alles und dann
gibt es noch eine weitere liebe in ihrem
leben
aber mir wohnt seit bald zwei jahren mit
michelle und amelia zusammen
was bedeutet dir sein michael ja
[Musik]
eigentlich alles ja es geht mir auch
innere sehr schwere zeit kurve zu kurve
und sage er auch ohne sie wäre ich jetzt
nicht da wo jetzt also wäre ich
vermutlich ziemlich woanders
ich hoffe er hat mehr cool federer zieht
das zusammengeschweißt einfach
freundschaft ja noch dann haben wir uns
nicht wagt den schritt
[Musik]
armin verdient sein geld als
lastwagenchauffeur michel bezieht noch
eine iv-rente
doch das will sie ändern ich wünsche mir
dass ich mich als träume erfüllen
der film ist ja für mich sehr
außergewöhnliches projektleiter vor der
tour 14 jahre lang habe ich mich schnell
begleiter mit der kamera und das ist
natürlich immer reicher die stanz könne
zwar normalerweise als filmautor partie
mit den rücken begleitet und nachbar
jahr bin ich einfach bei der uck sie mit
ihren behaupten schwierig als filmautor
die stanz und natürlich das ist ein
großes thema andere filmprojekte manche
über 22 jahre begleitet haben
dann wirds halt mit der größte feind zu
und dem abwägen kann ich da jetzt greife
ich handle oder muss ich meine rolle als
filmautor war jetzt mich sehr
interessieren wir ihr der film ein
wunder hat michael sauber und die hand
trug das über viele kennt und über froh
dass man reber aus schwierigen
situationen kann der wagen finden und
dann dass er so über home bietet
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer bin ich
sehr dankbar aber mich hören jetzt
reaktionen natürlich vor ihrer sieht
sehr interessiert und spannt man heute
filme michael interessiert hat würde ich
orientiere
mein körper mein werk das ich in filmen
dokumentarfilme view niveau fitness
machen dann zum teil vorstadt linien
fitnesswahn innere mit oder dann mein
körper mein feind das sind frauen mit
essstörungen
beide filme verlinkt